Anti TPO superior a 1000 como baixar
então Eh quando você fala de níveis de
anticorpos anti tiroidianos aumentados
então nós estamos falando geralmente da
doença de Hashimoto a tiroidite de
Hashimoto e mais raramente A tiroidite
dequem então isso é uma situação muito
frequente e o que você tem que fazer
para poder reduzir esses anticorpos
primeiramente é limpar sua dieta E como
é que você faz para limpar a dieta
cortar os alimentos processados
alimentos industriais ados os corantes
educ corantes espessantes todos esses
elementos são colocados nos alimentos
artificiais então também é importante
você eliminar os alimentos mais
inflamatórios da sua alimentação fora os
processados que é o caso do glúten leite
e derivados então é muito importante
você ter uma dieta rica em vegetais rica
em gordura saudável proteína adequada
para que você possa recuperar de uma
forma mais adequada e só comer alimentos
que vem da natureza sem processamento e
além de você mudar a sua dieta é muito
importante também você gerenciar o seu
estresse gerenciar o seu sono fazer
atividade física regular e tomar alguns
suplementos que ajudam bastante antes de
falar do suplementos inclua alimentos
ricos em odo como frutos do mar e
alimentos ricos em selênio na sua
alimentação como é o caso de noses e
sementes faça a suplementação com
selênio se você tiver deficiência desse
mineral e deixa eles noos limites
superiores da normalidade porque ele
ajuda muito na saúde da tireoide e a
reduzir os anticorpos antipo ômega-3
também ajuda bastante pelos seus efeitos
antiinflamatórios os probióticos também
vão ajudar porque eles vão colaborar pro
equilíbrio da Saúde intestinal que tem a
ver com esses anticorpos e de
suplementação você pode usar a
naltrexona de baixa dosagem que eu uso
bastante para questão aí de tio de
rimoto e o óleo de cominho preto também
ajuda bastante e se você tiver com
hipotiroidismo ou seja se a sua tireoide
não tiver produzindo hormônios
suficientes Você pode ter que tomar o
hormônio né T4 a levotiroxina e alguns
casos também com Associação da
triodotironina T3